how are friends I'm Alana and welcome to
my channel today's video probably isn't
going to look or sound that good because
I am unboxing the single largest and
most expensive statue I have ever bought
I've been thinking about it and I
haven't been able to figure out a way
that I could get a microphone to walk
because I'm gonna have to move a lot
because the box is like half of my
height more than that probably but also
my camera's probably gonna have some
focus problems it's just a whole thing
but I'm so excited about this I've been
looking at this statue at conventions
and installs behind display cases for
such a long time and when it came out
and I saw the price I had you know
months of being like oh I probably
shouldn't do this this is probably not a
good idea but then I resolved myself to
making it be lost statue that I buy for
a very very very long time
um well anything you in 2020 preloaded
this last year it just only came this
year because they take a long time to
make so I was like [ __ ] I'm gonna do
it but then I arrived several months ago
and I haven't unboxed it because I'm
also having the dread of living in a
studio apartment where every surface I
have is already covered in statues and
collectibles video gable [ __ ]
so I don't know where I'm going to put
it and I think it as soon as i unbox it
I have to deal with the reality that I'd
done something that I probably shouldn't
have just because I love it you know and
looking at it makes me really happy so
I'm really excited this is going to seem
insane to some of you because this thing
is enormous and ugly and expensive but
for me I feel like I've been looking
forward to this day for a really long
time and I can't wait so let's [ __ ]
unbox the prime one studio Batman who
lost statue let's do it I wasn't joking
it's really big
it comes with assembly instructions
that's really uncommon
okay well you know it's not a know that
much of a good reveal because they're
all covet Kate oh my god oh my god I
can't wait this rules I'm so excited
like literal chain this really is gonna
require assembly huh I've been
collecting since I was I don't know
probably 14 when it comes to collector's
editions and whenever and I started to
get like into it more and more with like
the kind of like more art related stuff
which is what I consider the statues
like this to be never have I gotten
pieces of chain that I have to attach to
different garrick utley joking
it comes with its own like faceplate oh
my god Robin this is one of the smallest
parts of this statue all the record that
could be a statue by itself geez
they've got this like gloss on his teeth
I'll show you call this closer up what I
can
oh my [ __ ] god this is so heavy and
so big look at another bad boy here
that's your own fan Robin there are
three
oh yeah particularly delightful nice
it's just so well painted just oh I
probably should be paying attention to
the assembly instructions it probably
wanted me to get the base out first and
then stop putting everyone else on it
but here we are
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] yes dude okay I think it's time for
right cavalry adjustment probably gonna
try to just build it for you guys
probably needed to face me to be in love
oh I'm sorry
[Music]
yeah I'm not gonna be able to get the
whole thing in frame so you know that's
a thing
[Music]
cool
look at these poses so sick he's like
he's like crawling off of it that's dope
so all I have left now all of these bits
of chain which I feel like it's gonna be
a little bit tough aside from the chain
it's pretty much done and it [ __ ]
rules oh my god oh my god
[Music]
okay this is the first two chains done
the instructions are so confusing but
they basically just like repeatedly and
loop back on themselves and basically
every photo there's like a different
amount of like slack like I guess this
one's probably a bit higher in these
pictures but they're all just different
so I really don't know
okay I think it's completely done I'm
swapping to my phone um cuz my cameras
roll when I hold it
so the chains were really [ __ ] hard
and I don't know if I'm 100% happy with
them um because the instructions just
made it really difficult but I did in my
best so this big guy he's holding all
these little guys and then the chain is
also wrapped around the base oh my god
it's just it's just so good um this
thing is like obviously it's my hand to
scale enormous and so oh god it's so
detailed yeah I really love that these
guys all have distinct facial
expressions and distinct poses this one
looks like he's kind of reaching out at
you which I like this is how pug boy
with his Unga bye beautiful like just
getting the whole thing in in a single
shot is impossible almost like flipped
the camera but my god I love it so this
is where I decided to put him he's right
between my couch and my fridge because
he fits there perfectly he is literally
you can see the size of my couch
Toula actually so when I'm [ __ ]
sitting over there playing video games
and have this dude next to me who is
basically the height of me excuse the
spray and wipe I just clean the floor
before I put him there but holy [ __ ] oh
my god yeah this there's also a disaster
of a mess just everywhere from the
amount of like paper that came with this
thing
I can't believe that's just chillin in
my [ __ ] apartment right now oh my god
and I guess this is where I have to
leave you all this is a bad unboxing but
a lot of very real excitement terribly
shot this sounds gonna suck my lens
doesn't fit him in frame so I want you
to up stop I warned you before I even
stopped recording I knew it would be a
problem okay but I'm really happy it's
so sick
also I finally got a Mary in my
apartment I've been to two years and I
only just go to Mira and I love that any
time that I ever happen to take a photo
in my mirror that thing is always gonna
be in the background cuz it's directly
behind my back oh god it's so good just
alright I hope this was at least
entertaining to watch because the
producer in me is it completely ashamed
by how I'm literally poorly produced
this is just terrible production Belly
top to bottom sorry about that but it's
not about me you know